fatality finish him what you suck damn
it huh hey hey give me Wow ha Takashi
[Music]
alright you put each this mission is
impossible but I know better I do know
better - you're better suited tryna
always knows what rekt spike fall once
again Cudi's we have found ourselves in
a situation where we're not bored by at
least I won the crazy smiley whoa whoa
hey now
oh wait a minute hold your horses I'm
very disturbed oh okay I don't want to
play this level anymore
[Applause]
Oh get away get away
thanks Mario you're the ball god I can't
yeah there we go okay thanks Mauro
you're the ball I'm gonna make it I
think oh no oh no oh this hand press
only forward button okay whatever you
say buddy bang tease balls what ha ha I
can't break that to break you have to go
this way oh okay why am I doing this
what is going on here skit ill crew
evacuate from the SIB marine owner
dealership Lauren Oliver Stone even
Yavin sternum I am a little Russian
don't if they take our potatoes lose I
grabbed it what do I do now it doesn't
this there this doesn't working buddy
this is not my okay losing wow that was
the most boring level I've ever played
in my entire life oh no I should
probably
no I did it before but I want to try it
again with me actually doing this done
[Music]
neon world Pogo man secret path yep oh I
can't fit in the hole get ready for the
pounding of your life look we're never
was
what wait a minute kids this time I
think was really screwed up this seems
to be a pogo jump I don't know excuse me
I'm feeling a bit too much let's go good
let's go propulsion I actually have to
take a second here and actually clean my
screen because of the copious amounts of
spit that I have shot at my screen hold
all right you I'm gonna smash the hell
out of you I've done so many bottle runs
barely made it through the easy level
[Music]
air attack broke up this patil labelled
comfortable school murder stroke in
Sydney Lear student a superstar and the
second is blurred in Florida snob Louvre
doll both Lenore how do i murder these
peoples hoax me are you pretty bastard
I'm not supposed to smash
[Applause]
[Music]
iso100
neon rainbow stairs how about you go kid
but I I phone level two what whoa what
whoa whoa i way down Oh ready for that
ah it's got me by the NARS minefield oh
really
I haven't played a minefield level since
like the first happy wheels highlights
oh here we go face roll technique oh
yeah oh you almost got my butt there but
not quite it is or impossible impossible
is just a word face roll technique
Oh can't touch this you touch asleep you
hard wait it got stuck ow
yeah you're gonna boost me up bro okay
ready proud Oh too much boosting alright
one more try
no just calm down I lost my helmet but
that's okay I don't need it
what okay yeah
hey stop that you're just a bully and
I'm gonna I'm gonna get you I'm gonna
get you buddy you're gonna you're gonna
pay for all that you've done
hahaha
I know buddy I'm still alive you son of
a [ __ ] you can't kill me
guy Ropin oh so this isn't a rope swing
it's a sky rope open it door open ha ha
oh that's who they exactly the same of
everything else i suck at not going to
suck not going to suck yes I am the
greatest oh look at me go I am so bottle
run another one I am too hang on I'm too
pro this is a long one I'm too proud for
you bro oh come on I'm gonna get this
it's now I've never failed a bottle run
before ever I'm gonna get it oh great
five [ __ ] um let's go this way
hey hey wait a minute all right let's do
this is a correct way if we have to I
guess whoa true Pro oh well I guess
that's done ha ha ha do bro do bro
bottle run easy oh yeah oh yeah oh the
glass break is always amount of my least
favorite it takes too long
oh [ __ ] it I give up I give up
all right kids once again we're in an
impossible level we'll show them who
really is impossible I don't even know
how you can fly
what is that sir more impossible than
this okay
stop blocking me oh oh wait a minute
ah no you couldn't I know we're a bit
too fat for this but let's see what we
can do
oh we're gonna fly it so shoot it well
we're so smaller yes all right you kids
we're gonna tie this a gun and don't
suck this time do not jiggle jiggle oh
don't get a locket hat rookie chat but
they're a job brute-force drug gang go
at them with your new model y'all off
like I was saying before cadets you need
to charge these think you threw nubile
young party you perfect item damn it
I've lost all propulsion I could survive
yes however could I have my god
Santa's got no arms say that's got no
arms Shanna's got no arms got a wife I
was making a whose line reference by the
by a neon sward throw hot [ __ ] um
okay let's try to hit something yeah
more like it oh I've won my little meat
shop is better than your meat shop oh no
I'm gonna strangle you
ah do not touch the right way I will
block it with this guy nubile young body
ha ha he took the blow for me no I lost
a leg but I am still alive I am now dead
rate 5 stars but why what are we doing
here
what are we doing there Ted my questions
what are we doing oh oh oh oh
Ted Ted Ted kids gone but I mean wow
what is I don't even understand what's
happening oh oh oh we just got a hold on
man use your abs use your abs do I win
I'm gonna let go now this has been happy
wheels highlights thanks for watching if
you like what you saw and you want to
see more why not subscribe to my channel
wanna help the channel grow leave a like
add in to your favorites or share it
with your friends on Facebook and
Twitter thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]